We've got the inequality negative x times
the expression
2x minus 14 is greater than or equal to
24.
So I encar, encourage you to pause this
video now and think about what the
solution
set to this inequality would actually be,
and
actually plot the solution set on a number
line.
So I'm assuming you've given a go at it,
so let's just try to simplify this a
little bit.
So on the left hand side we could
distribute, we could
distribute this negative x, and so if we
did that we
would get negative 2, negative 2x squared,
negative times a negative
is a positive, plus 14x is greater than or
equal to 24.
Now I'm gonna put the, I'm gonna subtract
24 from both sides, just so that we just
have a 0 here and then we can think about
factoring what we have here on the left.
So we have negative 2x squared, plus 14x,
I'm gonna subtract
24 from both sides, so it's minus 24 is
greater than
or equal to, I've subtracted 24 from the
right as well,
so that's going to be greater than or
equal to 0.
Now, I don't like, I don't like having
this negative 2 out front, so
what I wanna do is I wanna divide this
left hand side by negative
2, but I can't just divide the left hand
side only by negative 2,
I have to do divide the right hand side by
negative 2 as well.
And anytime I multiply or divide both
sides of an
inequality by a negative number, it's
going to flip the inequality.
So if I divide both sides by negative 2,
I'm going to be
left with x squared, positive x squared
minus, so I'm
dividing by negative 2, so minus 7x, plus
12.
And now since I divided by negative 2, I'm
gonna flip this inequality,
is less than or equal to zero divided by
negative 2 is 0.
So that simplified things a good bit, and
now
let's see if we can factor this quadratic
expression.
So two numbers whose product is positive
12, so that means they're
gonna have the same sign, and whose, and
whose sum is negative 7.
So if they have the same sign, and their
sum is
negative 7, that tells us that they're
both going to be negative.
And let's see, negative 3 and negative 4
seem to fit the bill.
Their product is positive 12.
Their sum is negative 7.
So we could write this as x minus 3 times
x
minus 4, is going to be less than or equal
to 0.
So now this is the point that we're gonna
do a little bit of interesting logic.
If the product of two things is less than,
is less than or equal
to 0, what does that tell us, tell what do
we know about it?
Well, that tells us that either, either
one or
both of them is 0, or they have different
signs.
The only way that you're gonna get less
than 0 is if one is
positive and the other is negative, or one
is negative and the other is positive.
So our 1 is negative, is that they have
different signs.
So let's write that down, let's write that
down.
So either, either x minus 3, x minus 3 is
less than
or, less than, either x minus 3 is less
than or equal
to 0 and, and x minus 4 is greater than or
equal to 0, x
minus 4 is greater than or equal to 0, so
notice, note
this one is non positive, this one is non
negative,
they're either equal to 0 or they are have
different signs.
So that's one situation, or, or the other
way around, or x
minus 3 is non negative, it's greater than
or equal to 0, and
x minus 4 is non positive, x minus 4 is
less than or equal to 0.
Once again, they're either zero or
different signs, that's all I'm
doing with this little with this little
logic work right over here.
So what are these, what is this, what is
this simplified to?
So x minus 3 less than or equal to 0, add
to both sides, you get x is less than or
equal to 3.
And, and x minus 4 is greater than or
equal to 0.
If you add 4 to both sides of this, you
get x is greater than or equal to 4.
So what values of x are going to be less
than
or equal to 3, and greater than or equal
to 4?
Well anything that's less than or equal to
3 is
not going to be greater than or equal to 4
and anything that's greater than or equal
to 4 is
not going to be less than or equal to 3.
So there's no x, there's no x value that
can satisfy
this situation right over here, there's no
X value that will
result in this one being negative, and
this one being, or
this one being non positive and this one
being non negative.
So let's go to this one right over here.
So if we add 3 to both sides, we get x is
greater than or equal to 3
and, and we get adding 4 to both sides, x
is less than or equal to 4.
Now does this make sense, that something
could be greater than
or equal to 3 and less than or equal to 4?
Sure, for example, well 3 is greater than
or equal
to 3 and is less than or equal to 4,
4 is greater than or equal to 3 and it's
less than or equal to 4 and anything in
between.
So we can plot the solution set here.
So this is actually all that matters.
Cuz this one, there's no situation which
that would've been true.
So this is the only thing, this is the
only thing that's gonna make this or part
true.
This part is always going to be false.
So if we wanted to make the solution set,
it would look something like this.
So if this is our possible values of x.
So let's say that that is 0, so this is 1,
2, 3,
and 4, 3 and 4, 3 and 4, x could be
greater than
or equal to 3, so it's greater than or
equal to 3.
But it's also let, it also has to be less
than
or equal to 4 so we can't just go all past
4.
Also, less than or equal, less is since
it's, less than or
equal we can color in these dots, less
than or equal to 4.
So anything in this range, including 3 and
4, that's why
we circled in the dots, this would satisfy
this equation here.
And if you wanted to think about it
visually, hey,
you know we know that this type of thing,
we know
that this type of thing, or this type of
thing, this
type of thing right over here, these are,
these are parabola's.
So how would that relate to this little
solution
set that we just thought about right over
here?
Well if you look at let's, let's just look
at one of these.
Let's say we went to, let's say we went to
this form right over here.
So all, everything we did, this is just
another way of thinking about
negative 2x squared plus 14x minus 24 is
greater than or equal to 0.
So this right over here, we have a
negative coefficient on
the x squared term, that's going to be a
downward opening parabola.
So when is that greater than or equal to
0?
So if, if we though about the
downward opening parabola, it could might
look something
like this, it might look something like
this if we're now thinking in 2
dimensions.
And this is the, this is the, if you think
of this as the Y axis right over here.
So when is that greater than or equal to
0?
Well it's greater than or equal to 0, it's
above
the X axis in this range for x right over
here.
So that's one way of thinking about it.
If we though about it from the point of
view, not of that parabola, not of that
parabola, but
this parabola right over here, when is x
squared
minus 7x plus 12 less than or equal to 0?
Well this is gonna be an up, upward
opening parabola.
So if it has a positive coefficient here,
so this problem might look something like
this, might look something like this, when
is it less than or equal to 0?
Well once again, once again it's less than
or equal to 0 in that same range.